Uh, I now eat coffee that I make and taste so good I eat the product I made
. In
a way, my experience and heart are there.
I eat it every morning with a hand drip on my neck. Yoga
coffee wakes up my soul. This is what I do every morning.
[Music]
First of all, I started a cafe. I stopped
being mine and gave the police. Tourists now like manicur feeds, so I started a coffee business and became
a cafe.
Oh, it worked really well.
I'll have to go into it more deeply,
any kind of coffee that comes out of it. Oh, I
think there's a possibility that there is a possibility of being able to create a product with three raw materials in it
.
That's
why recovery noodles become coffee beans.
Then, if you order them to an alcohol bar, it becomes wine,
and making
cosmetics with it again becomes cosmetics.
It's true that some cosmetic companies don't come out with world-class brands, but because their
products are dedicated to the Jumbo Hey Cam Cal process, the natural cosmetics are a bit
lacking.
It is said that there
is antioxidant, and it is more sensitive to skin in the United States,
so I saw a cut if it was effective as a cosmetic.
slightly
[music]